this is
okay now
let me call that okay
oh cool I mean now say forget it what's
here oh it's you I was about to ask her
out now here's a question when you're in
the when you're in the closet yeah and
and we opened up you have the masculine
of the two sides did you want that on as
well it doesn't matter either way I
might be good for lighting tonight
because if I wear it mic over my face or
whatever so ready yeah and we're kind of
like high up like that like like that
yeah then we can't see the lawyers yeah
I be alright we should probably keep it
off okay okay cool
first thing we're gonna do is yeah just
us walking into to the scene they're
saying our lines we it's jr. yeah yes
yes yeah it's the proper Celtic way of
saying it yeah polish Polish polish name
oh yeah wow yeah wow the more you know I
have to put that in wait chocolate bacon
yeah or granny's oh no I just make me
like go to Burger antics if you want the
most wonderful hamburgers that are
amazing so were they Brooke for granted
vegetarian yeah yeah oh oh they do
oh they do oh no I don't know I thought
you were saying that they do okay so
what it's gonna be because we in the
except slight sound uh it's gonna start
off gonna grown Rob you'll be a belt
right there yeah but right there by were
through oh but we're done now consumer
and I are going to come out having a
conversation we're going to be talking
about reviewing the Fantastic Four movie
and I'll probably
if you maybe a little bit there or no no
you're right you're right you're right
where you were because we are honest yes
because we're going to cross around this
way and we're going to go to the storage
closet
so as we pass by just go ahead and kind
of follow us and turn around this one
for the fanfic writers yes nostalgia
critic and Tamra go to the storage
closet Oh Malcolm any malko and we found
that we find RJ is Menasha Tammet well
yes so so yes your guess yes and you're
gonna follow us pretty much over to the
storage closet follow back Robbie was
like a play on Tamra's named dr. Tama
talk I just laugh and I don't know what
some things mean okay if that one's
really funny you know you'll never on
that Bush what okay so so we're so we're
gonna be coming out of there and I said
I told you we just did a fantastic for
review we can't do another but it's so
bad I don't care
they couldn't even spell it right I
don't care about half a percent o Rotten
Tomatoes
how did do that it found a way fan for
stick fan for stick that's the way it's
spelled so I you know I'll let him say
that no no no other ways no no will sit
they could even spell it right fan for
stick yeah say that we will have that
line and yeah so it found a way on and I
start to open the closet so that's all
the shots gonna be so yeah go ahead uh
yeah I pretty much have my lines are
pretty easy so yeah you two go ahead
look that over all right either what
yeah and I guess I'll put this down yeah
I'll go I'm the ninja to the city sir
yes I agree
I concur
like this also tracking shotgun I think
will do actually um first thing we'll do
this will do the flash background like
on the phone and I see yeah I'm just
like yeah yeah yeah so let's see about
so pretty much that's gonna be I think
we have like one line okay great to
cross over
all right ah see I face should be bigger
on the merit card and then the nerd on
the tail car with a beer ninja
transparently uh okay I seem so
ridiculous is with two sides okay so uh
rub yeah here's what we're going to do
so here Andre I'll have you okay waiting
there
yeah just our heavier size of Callaghan
icon for like oh yeah or probably does
this even get right there so we can sort
all right so what's going to be as uh
I'm going to be probably like right here
I'll be saying you know I don't care if
he's the bigger star I want my face
bigger on the type of car than the nerd
ding-dong I don't care I shuffle with it
uh hold on a second come in hey critic I
heard you in a turtle crossover yeah
sure come on in
ya know who's the bigger trophy than me
okay so I didn't know about that show or
that show or not show wow that did you
sure they know it well anyway I'm the
bigger fan you hear me everything should
be bigger including that don't ask me
how I know it's bigger and then we can
get there that's great so I just white
not going at them huh kind of sister sis
is it no do you have any of this shot
for you okay
like rub no I think oh um I'll just have
to walk backwards yeah I'm gonna have to
be out the we did you want me to run
through it again so we have okay okay
actually if you want to put a different
way about size 9 that's fine okay so
here I am and I don't care if there's a
bigger star my face should be bigger on
the title card I don't care it's just
what it is
who's a bigger ninja troubles manner
than me a critic I heard you're going to
turtle crossover yeah sure come on in
okay so what if I didn't know about that
show or that show or that show
underneath that show - that's innate but
it doesn't I'm still the bigger fan so I
should be able to have the bigger face
everything about these fingers on a nerd
including that don't ask me how I know
that yeah okay okay does it matter if
you see the edge of this like just much
I mean because there's almost junk here
anyway you can't really hear you just
hope you do that you're going to hear
clean but I just never did it and as you
leave under alright alright now I'm
gonna Cassie okay okay go ahead trip to
the drive-thru action I don't care if
the nerd is the bigger star my face
should be bigger on the title card come
on who's a bigger Ninja Turtles man than
me hey critic are you doing a crossover
with the nerd yeah sure come on here I
don't care if he knows more about the
show I know more about all the shows
except that or that I don't even know
they made that one as that's in it
nevertheless I am the bigger fan so I
should be bigger the title card
everything about these bigger than a
nerd including that don't ask how I know
that good
this is Andre hello
I'm Andre and I'm up in the closet got a
bandana on me phase and since I Mahan
supposed to be Raphael Ninja Turtles but
don't lock me in a closet he opened up
the door I saw muckerman turn around and
also saw Doug's dad and there's dummies
walking by this is brother Bob are you
ready to come out of the Falcon yeah
yeah do some videos with these guys
what'd I miss - side to side to side
chapter 57 you are Kelly were a ninja
turtle fan that's coming soon yes
how much finish but for someone saying
april O'Neil she took the better job
ever making five sheep deliver the best
fruit on the other time besides rock
singer I hope you hold it from like it
should be okay that's good I can pop you
might like it one of your children like
you shot it I want to saw
is it is yes always knowing a times D
does this okay I agree it's my um oh so
it just goes together like LEGO pieces
yeah hey just pop them in together and
there you go there's it
oh wow there he goes that's how weapons
are made all right hey you handcrafted
ha ha ha ha ha you'll quality so you're
all right
Oh what's a forge all right well just
like all stooped down help I'm why are
they serious you made me just scoot over
- there you go you need to go go
and now I can put the camera oh it was
mph is like weird hallucinogenic acid
flashbacks from Harold & Kumar Go to
White Castle then when he was on the
ludes or whatever this was the shit he
was seeing are you sitting somewhere -
Harold in Cooper's car over he's like
Eva's whole smurf adventure
I'm an advertising executive any food
blue people are coming in because I was
waiting for the unicorn any second okay
so it doesn't have to be exactly the
corner route but somewhere I'm going to
need you on the ground just pointing
upward like this and we're gonna be
doing like a rapping to the camera yes
sorry hey do you want us wearing any
like shades or looking cool
I mean they didn't show I think it's
like if it's just us but we'll be like
you know whoa whoa well of a bitch you
know yeah yeah why don't you guys have
to get all blue twice oh yeah well you
know if you did daddy Doug needs to be
an all blue makeup yeah yeah I've had to
be an all no makeup no makeup and
Malcolm needs to be Smurfette all right
Oh God
wait no so we're like good okay I mean
what is going perfect yeah the legs are
getting what you think I didn't whoa
sibling wearing a jersey the SNL Smurfs
sketch oh yes but I all don't be as
funny now because like they don't do
those as much tonight
that was closer to the Smurfs do you
want to camera movements yeah did a
little bit a moment yeah if you're gonna
do it just very kind of slowly rolling
okay go ahead on the set so we're gonna
go love bitch bitch bitch
yeah action la la la la la la bitch la
la la la
bitch yeah yeah this one Little John the
hair this is I feel like I've just been
raped by spoon
we all have worn or Smurfs bachelor ah
too much I think what I got somebody
spit in my face no it's an honor if it's
him he can go to hell
watched you today Oh Bravo just on the
ground holding a camera watch spit I
don't know baby help my face you know I
felt like I'm speech by Lamar a park
where those giant faces fade a bit on
the tourists he's on me yeah he's making
up our own verbs maybe he thought you
about your contribution I've got hate
upon it so it was like a except
Shakespeare yeah yeah
so sorry about that virility it's okay
it was an honor to accept you see Rob
collects you now you have radioactive
powers yes I agree I can play here yes I
can like teenage beam into Turtles elite
school when I do it yeah no no yes there
it is try though that's kind of it yeah
we're just gonna mind it it in Malviya
chamber good
like you know how he's doing yeah it's
like what are you doing oh you got a
little uh a little fuzz Oh blue oh girl
no but you hair I'm starting it to a
smirk yeah blue hair you're going blue
hair yes
well where's you're going followed by
turning on Dodgers in their sang in the
bud it's pretty good
Jack been happy wouldn't be good yeah
that's a really good time that's
actually oh you know who Tom notches
Three's Company to the way he said I was
feeling I know I mentioned I'm a nice
older person that would be his response
Fatty Arbuckle the first person I said
okay Tamra can get you up here
okay so we bring you okay so um I think
we move this table um Alcantara you two
are going to be right here we're going
to be wrapping in that corner um and
you're gonna be saying those lines there
you can hold my move this table oh it's
just like that oh I guess I could it
might be kind of wanted I record
everything we're taking down the oh
thank you we're taking down the pop quiz
hotshot role so we can easily put back
up but we're also taking down Victoria's
drawings looks great and all there's
others have come into the end I just
like if you want them on camera it's
your fault Rob yeah totally side pointed
that maybe we wouldn't want it on camera
but it doesn't matter to me Johnny
goodbye Barney I'm Malcolm good stick
yeah because keep Rob you shall bury
little Larry today's relying on beaming
huh you shut your whore mouth oh well
escalated ready tell people Rob just
points to the board it doesn't it and I
just fun to mix it just mine fine
we said come on and now it's gone okay
that is fucking insulting my Hitler's
way better I took German you know yes in
college yeah should demonstrate how much
you know I know how to say beer bitter
bitter yeah how do you say it
oh my god he's right you yeah you don't
know how to say danke Schoen or else the
hot German Barbie this won't you know
well anyway yeah you truly are German
say it was German the less I can see you
try to sell this picture so I'm always
in Maiko I'm in blue and green make up
Malcolm make up your lack there enough
where you tell a Mitch I use why what
were you thinking you're not racist
that's Arisa I love that show racist was
a great show smart about Jail oh yeah
she's up to stuff she's up to stefan's
better than Sister Sister I can tell you
whoa you shut your mouth don't you ever
talk bad about the sisters in my friend
I say okay Sister Sister Sister Sister
had the most annoying themes of any show
what happened to way twisted much I
missed it yeah everybody knows I did you
really had a second theme song oh yeah
that's I've never heard this leg without
when they got it got like you got all
soldier like
like Family Matters yeah what a
wonderful world yeah I did not know that
that was all watching that MUC wow
that's a yes little tidbit for y'all
Family Matters original theme song was
what a wonderful world Wow same intro
same cut but played what a wonderful
world
just carl winslow just yeah Louie yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah we go it it looks
more like you one of those like sappy
kind of dramas you would have seen on
like W beers yeah like it so does that
fit like a goofy Sitka yeah but then
ergo came in and changed everything
oh yeah corresponding entertainment hey
Jim make it five Wow
I've got my oh yeah only in my own time
oh yeah yeah yeah that's the hundred was
close your camera oh yeah yeah yes
that's good even we do series of reviews
Orson yes Rises stick my head in this
bucket of cocaine just pretend this
didn't happen
that's rubber Tom juniors cremated
remains
oh that was a turkey that I can turn in
a high and a little crowd to me that was
why the the crowning turn yes and this
is how the director of special guest
Anna
that's what's gonna be nowhere near
mean-spirited enough Oh damaged Smurfs
good to me yeah let me do home alone
three hey mamasan Big Momma's House Wow
hit it on this with your vampire
say like why don't we did Big Momma's
House I love that movie
that's the prequel to every Tyler Perry
Madea movie yeah Oh Big Momma Phantom
Menace excellent you're on smoking issue
and then it was definitely a menace and
it was an unknown phantom thing on the
horizon and we don't know about you yes
your first sister yes sister that's the
season I started on was with the new
yeah just do it here I think we're just
me holding thrones' game oh you're just
going to be going in and out of like you
know rock let's go whoa whoa I mean
there's no real sound needed so okay and
action
this
okay now likes to rock was enjoying it
yy-yeah the rocks gonna need to see it
there especially after the money for
Fort Wayne the rock Johnson yes yeah
where's your waiting the rock John fifty
thousand movies he's making ahead right
here's I think he's doing he's doing DZ
oh fuck Dwayne the rock good job
no I mean seriously very very sexy man
yeah you wanna do it and see him in D's
on the screen at the same time oh man he
knows what I'm talking about I knows
what he talking about right ladies right
right I'm talking about you ladies oh I
can smell what The Rock is pickin Oh YUM
I need to go take a shower
hey there's so much need lip gloss
everybody Wow oh good good look at our
guest shot and glare Hey okay um let's
have uh Malcolm guy have you be over
there robbery the same thing is I'm
gonna use this whole half okay yes no no
no oh yeah Neal had no nothing but they
have nothing in common
yeah uh I'm Neil Patrick Harris ya know
the Shia LaBeouf is just gonna be the
green screen at him so just kiss me
right now see oh there are people there
yes
okay I'm hi again oh you're gonna put
them yeah okay no so it's gonna be Neil
Patrick Harris is he had executive bacon
Fox is a ver O'Neill shall upon from
Transformers just da okay Jesus a little
swatch from the Tom and Jerry movie yeah
you know you
Jacquizz you know how you want it to
look for pokes yeah and no real sound is
needed here so I mean I think you can
just revealing how big yeah
yeah okay ready and action
Neil Patrick Harris as the ad executive
Megan Fox as april O'Neil shuttle
evolved from transformers dude okay
Jesus the little twat from Tom and Jerry
movie and this weird convertible thing
I'm not gonna say cuz it's a lot of
words
um he's they're good yeah okay
should be good alright we'll do one more
hey call me Chris Chris Rock you can
call me Chris Chris Rock Taiwan cos fuck
call me Chris Chris Rock good good um I
got more in me quick if you want to
happen if you're offering you're just
saying that and Christopher Walken
little winter wonderland occasion what
is she okay I say I didn't think you
were gonna say yes yes you fire I got
you gonna say fuck off okay Malcolm we
need you to do samulet all right this
has potential guys this daljeet I think
that critic is going there's something
to this nostalgia critic though is it
Rhett retro critic area
Rachel cometary commentator so yeah I
don't think it's gonna catch on I think
the language is really bad yeah oh yeah
isn't that winner don't get won by the
one doctor mother - yeah yeah the
language is really bad and if you didn't
give her
we'll say all like the f-word books then
she would really be upset that she reads
those in Pride
oh and I guess that's a wrap that's it
we're done everybody go home
oh my gosh are you oh yeah so go go to
bed well maybe some of you are in bed